what's that belief nation welcome to
another entrepreneur AMA I'm super
pumped to be here again to answer your
questions you got me for a little bit of
time we'll see how long this one runs
I'm excited I feel like it's been a
while since you did an AMA I've had some
great guests on the past couple weeks
and so it's been some interesting
conversation but now it's just me and
you get to answer your questions live
this is the first video that I'm doing
live I think that has my new play button
if you guys check out over there I got
my gold million subscriber play button
here the silver one is the little one
you see how much bigger the gold one
I'll bring it over let's celebrate
right look at that there it is 1 million
congratulations on passing 1 million
subscribers that play button anyway I
did an unboxing video with it with Nina
it's coming live on the channel at some
point after all my vacation videos are
done with the life with Evan but now
let's get to questions guys hit me up
the live chat is blowing up already it's
a lot easier guys if you tagged me on
the question so I can see it so let's go
what do we got I see a lot of chatter
let's get questions what do we got
hi Evan how do you find good teammates
junkie stuff so it starts with values
for me it's believe it's figuring out
what you stay in for what the mission is
that's that has to be this the
foundation point then I'm looking at who
and my network that I already know I
love hiring friends I love working with
family i I think people have an aversion
to it and there's good reasons to avoid
it - depends you personality but I
immediately look for people who are in
my community already that I know I see
Lily in the live chat lily and I are
partners on her business venture and I
knew her from Trinidad salsa and I told
her while she was an instructor like
we're gonna do something together I
don't know when it's gonna be where it's
gonna be what its gonna look like but if
you want to start something let me know
and you know a year or two later boom
here we are and so starting with your
network is
is a great place thinking about people
who share the same values as you but
have different skill set to complement
you and then third if you have to go
outside then I'm looking at making a job
posting putting an ad out and I always
leave with the mission I always leave
any job ad with I want a photographer
who believes in entrepreneurs and I'll
talk about the mission before ever
getting to what the roles and
responsibilities are because I want
somebody who who loves it who believes
it right who bleeds it and breathes it
that's what I want and people who'd see
that job add a lot of them will just
wash away they'll look at it say that's
really stupid I don't like that and
great like don't apply we won't we won't
work out together and others will look
at that and say this is amazing
I want to go apply I can't wait to work
there and so I have a video on my
channel called the hiring process is
broken it's a couple years old but it's
still the exact same process that I use
right now and I highly recommend if that
is what you are looking at to watch that
video because I break my entire process
down in a lot more detail so go check it
out next chart your trade adapting the
question from Tim Ferriss what is the
worst piece of advice you hear others
give entrepreneurs I think the worst
piece of advice that I've ever given and
that I hear other people give I think
the worst piece of advice is when you
see the world through your eyes and not
the person's eyes so when you come and
ask me a question about your situation I
answer it the way that I would respond
to it how I would deal with that
situation instead of trying to
understand you your situation and give
you the best advice for you I think
that's that's the biggest mistake that
people make and give an advice not
understanding the subject I've been
doing a lot of Instagram live recently
Mike Michael I know you joined me
recently yesterday and a couple other
times before and what I love about it is
when I'm getting asked questions YouTube
Zillah harder because just a sentence
right it's just a live chat and it's
hard for me to know the context but when
I get on the Instagram live I can ask
you a couple questions I can get to know
you a little bit better I can understand
your situation a little better so
can tailor the advice to help fit your
situation where I think the worst advice
you give is here's how I would do it and
not even preferencing it with here's how
I do it say you need to do it like this
which is how you would do it but it's
it's not always the best thing for them
and so having that awareness to know
that your method is not always a method
for them I think really helps and I
probably made that mistake tons of times
but trying to get better next Shanta of
all the things you've learned from many
leaders what was the toughest habit to
implement in your life what was the
toughest habit to implement in my life I
don't know there's one toughest habit I
would just I would just say the habit is
tough until you decide to make it a
priority I find for me some things I'll
just click and right away I have to go
do that and I have a goal and this is
going to happen and it just is gonna
happen on a daily basis and I just
decided and that happens a lot in my
life and and I've learned to lean in on
those moments and trust them in and go
all in as soon as I get an instinct for
something I'll do it whether that's a
habit or whether that's even just
something I want to try even though the
workshop I'm doing in Toronto in May I'm
working with up to 15 people helping
them learn how to make money from their
ideas be a thought leader be the do what
I do but in your industry and make money
doing it and I just decided that I want
to do it and then within one day I had
the website up and functioning that
people could sign up and buy and then I
started talking about it on my Instagram
and on social media and so I just
decided and so leaning in and so for
habit sometimes that comes to and I'll
just snap and do it but those aren't the
hard ones the hard ones are more I'm
thinking about it I want to do it but I
haven't really decided yet you know
there's a little bit of smoke but
there's no fire yet you know just it's a
little bit it's just it's about to take
off but you see the smoke coming up
first and so as an example as an example
my trainer wants me to do a certain
amount of cardio every week so I work
with Trena Sean catalyst trainings and
he has we do
what am I at now 1,400 calories on the
bike I need the bike it's basically 140
minutes on the bike every week and some
weeks I hate it some weeks I didn't hit
it some weeks I hit it I didn't make it
a priority and then just last week I'm
like this this has to happen
I just sided it's gonna happen and so
every morning I'm up you know Monday
Monday my TDs but Tuesday to Friday I'm
up in the morning and I get to the bike
I did it this morning for anybody who
followed me on Instagram you might have
seen some posts I do it in the morning
hit my 35 minutes times for I hit my
target and before deciding it was when
we gonna find the time I got a have
other stuff in the morning can I do what
in the afternoon I'm tired at night I
got other things happening and I've Nina
I've hated is all these are the things
and really it's just excuses right does
that make it tough tough to implement
sure but then I just decided and it's
funny when you decide how things use
open up it's not tough anymore you just
do it and so I think if you are having a
difficult time implementing a habit
whether that's waking up at a certain
time whether that's you're doing
something you're afraid of with us
hitting the gym whether that's making
your calls the only reason that that's
really tough because is because you
haven't decided
you haven't really decided this is what
has to happen and when you make that
decision it becomes easy next what do we
got Michael is a best to find one thing
a niche in an area or wider so my
recommendation is starting off in a
niche being the best at something and
then expanding it's how a lot of
companies have built and grown I think
the challenge at the beginning of any
business or at the beginning of any
venture or idea or plan is that you will
have a hard time being great at it
because you're at the beginning and
you're starting and nobody knows you and
you're still actually getting good at
the thing that you're trying to sell and
so to try to hit a major market if
you're trying to hit for example you
want to hit entrepreneurship there's
lots of great people who are experts at
entrepreneurship if you have to go up if
you're going to create an
entrepreneurship channel
you have to go up against my channel
need to go up against your visa channel
you have to go against me for Leo's
channel and grant cardones channel and
all these people have entrepreneur
channels it's it's gonna be hard for you
to win but if you love exotic cars and
the buying and selling of exotic cars
you want to help entrepreneurs who want
to be in exotic cars that's a lot easier
to stand out with and so it's much
easier to start at a combination of what
you love doing those entrepreneurship +
exotic cars right + making videos right
those three things that that's a talent
that you have a skillset and interest
that you have that most people won't
have we won't have that combination and
so that's an easy opportunity for you to
win and then you develop your expertise
there and then you expand and you grow
and you grow and you're going you can
get wider even looking at my channel as
an example I started only doing
entrepreneurs every top-10 was an
entrepreneur I thought I'm willing to do
entrepreneurs I don't want to branch out
it's just entrepreneurs that's who I
want to focus on I kept getting asked to
do athletes and musicians and actors my
god I don't I don't want to do that I'm
focused on entrepreneurship and then I
started looking at Michael Jordan he was
the first non entrepreneur that we did
and listen Michael Jones an entrepreneur
he's a he he's a billionaire he's made a
lot of good business decisions but he's
not known as being an entrepreneur he's
known for his basketball and so I
watched some of his content and realized
Michael Jordan's got a lot of great
things to say that can help
entrepreneurs about success about Drive
about hardwork about dedication about
teamwork all that stuff I can make a top
10 video on him I think it could be
applicable and relevant for
entrepreneurs I'm not gonna make a video
from Michael about how to dunk or how to
make a free throw right or what he eats
for breakfast but I'm making stuff about
entrepreneurship that's relevant and so
I started being purely entrepreneurs now
if you look at my content because of the
Michael Jordan how we expanded I'd say I
don't know at least half of this of the
top tens that we do are not what you
would consider to be an entrepreneur
right they're singers actors musicians
athletes politicians people from all
walks of life and so
that's how I started that's how I grew
same thing for you figure out what your
niche is be the best be seen as the
expert in that field and then you can
slowly expand expand expand expand
beyond if you start way out here your
message is gonna likely get lost because
you're going up against big competition
and you could do it but you have to be
really really really really good
and that's hard at the beginning of a
venture so that's my suggestions good
luck next I'll be what will be the
future of this world
what will dominate the world after some
years I don't know I'll be I don't I
don't see here trying to make
predictions I try to react to the world
that is I think this is there's enough
to do with the world that is and trying
to predict where the world is going but
I'm sure there's lots of other channels
and thought leaders that can help you
with that one Rebecca how hard is
bookkeeping in paying tax what do you do
if you made a mistake
so listen bookkeeping and accounting is
one of the first things that I think
most entrepreneurs should give up
especially accounting not just because
most people hate it most people hate
accounting like if you ask most
entrepreneurs they hate doing the
numbers they hate doing the accounting
side of things most people hate doing
the legal side of things too the reason
why you want to get an accountant is one
to just make yourself feel less stressed
that you don't do all this stuff that
you hate to a good accountant will end
up saving you money they understand how
you can save on taxes any more than pay
for themselves now you know if you're
only making $1,000 in your business or
$10,000 in your business you know the
the $2,000 to hire the accountant is
probably not going to be worth but as
you start making a little bit more money
you definitely want to look into get an
accountant on top of it you want to make
sure you're filing your taxes properly
right you don't want the government
coming after you I'm Canadian so we have
a different tax code different structure
but you know if you're in the US I
definitely do not want the IRS on my
tail it really just depends on how big a
mistake that you made for a lot of the
accounting stuff for small businesses
you know you tend to get lucky because
the IRS the government's they don't care
about cracking down that much on small
business they do they do it but they
just they don't make enough money doing
it and there's so many small businesses
out there that chances are you're going
to you know fly through right it's like
going to the airport and you have to
press that random bag check right that's
that's what it is
you know the randomly spot check if
something is a huge red flag then yeah
they're gonna be calling you but most of
the time it's a random spot check and
most of the time you get through but
that's not a great strategy right like
as soon as you start making some money
with with your business I would look at
how do I get an accountant on board not
a bookkeeper because the bookkeeper is a
lot it's more expensive over the course
of a year and then a good accountant can
teach you what to do on the bookkeeping
side but get a good accountant to help
you with all the filing taxes and the
strategy and advice then as you continue
to grow you can do get a bookkeeper good
luck I hope I hope it works out
sucks do we chase for the government ah
next Chris Young do you recommend an LLC
to entrepreneurs yeah again I'm so I'm
Canadian I don't want to dive too much
into into legal issues especially in the
US but there's there's a little
difference between there's a difference
between being a sole proprietorship and
having a corporation the the biggest
ones are as a corporation you don't have
personal liability so if it's a sole
proprietorship if it's just you then if
something happens and somebody Sue's you
the United States is a lot more
litigious a lot more lawsuits happening
then they can go after everything you
own right they can go after your house
go after your car go after any assets
that you have
because everything's under your personal
name if you have a corporation then they
can't then they can only go after
whatever the corporation owns whatever
money assets that is in a company but
they can't touch you personally and so
you have to do the calculation and think
what kind of business are you in and how
likely you're going to get sued you know
a business like mine I'm making videos
you know I have books I'm not doing
anything that really can lead to people
getting sued in my Toronto then salsa
business you know there's more of a
possibility what if somebody gets
injured what if somebody hurts
themselves what if
somebody falls in the floor and breaks
her arm I mean we have insurance for
that but there's a higher risk of being
suits you want to make sure that's
definitely the corporation and and you
get some insurance around it so the
downside of the corporation is you have
to pay more you have to pay to get it
set up there's a little bit of hassle
and you have extra accounting and legal
fees accounting fees every single year
because you need to go file I need to
have your books reviewed by an
accountant and so it's gonna cost you
well not a lot more a couple thousand
dollars but if you're just getting
started you may not want to pay that you
may want to use that 2k to put into your
business and get product and samples and
marketing so I would say if you are in
an industry where you're really worried
about getting sued then you should go
corporation right away if you're an
industry where is a super low likelihood
and you don't have any massive assets
that you know on the books go sole
proprietorship and as soon as you can
afford to go into a corporation Salima
thank you for the super chat 279 I can
get I just got a coffee got a coffee
this morning Salima the next Tim Hortons
coffee is on you I appreciate it
insta our YouTube to make content
initially so there's definitely a piece
of personal preference in here depending
on what you like to do but if I was
getting started Instagram is a lot
easier to win at a couple reasons why
one YouTube is is more polished the
quality needs to be more polished like
it's hard to just make phone videos off
your phone with with zero editing and
win you can you have to have a great
message but it's harder to win or
Instagram it's a lot easier Instagram
especially be using the stories the
stories it's so easy because it's meant
to be raw it's meant to not be fancy and
meant to be edited and Instagram gives
you a whole bunch of tools to be able to
to do that properly but it's meant to be
a behind the scenes so I do a lot of my
Instagram content like I'm on the bike
I'm damning people responding to people
it's just a lot easier to win Instagram
is still a mostly picture economy it's
moving to video but my pictures still
outperform the videos that I'm doing the
videos are also short form right one
minute max on Instagram
versus YouTube and I'm working on my
Instagram now right I just cross 10,000
I love it it's the grinds like it's
nothing I'm starting from the beginning
compared to 1.2 million on YouTube and
it's just so easy for anybody who's
doing YouTube I'm making 3 videos a day
that are that are 10 20 minutes long
each to go to Instagram and make 3
one-minute videos or 3 pictures a day is
just so ridiculously easy it's so much
easier to do than to get on YouTube and
so it's still about making content that
you care about making content that means
something to you posting messages that
that resonate that isn't just you know
repost in somebody else but like touches
here what is your message what do you
want to share and put that out and then
the last thing I would say is Instagram
their algorithm especially using the
hashtags properly if you're just getting
started up I would look at categories
that are super targeted to your content
that have less than 5,000 posts and post
of those categories post sales hashtags
use 20-25 hashtags for every post super
targeted and not that competitive and
you could start to win as a small
influencer on Instagram you could start
to actually gain traction gaining
audience compared to YouTube you you
struggle and you grind and you grind and
then you start getting some traction and
then they start promoting you I'm just
starting my Spanish and French YouTube
channels and it's from scratch it's from
the beginning and we post amazing
content there some of my best videos in
English we transcribe and put it and
some of them are dubbed and we and we
put them up on the other channels and 50
views it's crazy now I have a
longer-term perspective it's gonna work
out I'm committing like hundreds of
videos before I cancel the channel
before I even look against in the
channel but Instagram you can stand it a
lot faster so if you're just calculating
if you're if your preferences are equal
either way Instagram is the hands-down
decision maker if you are if you have an
affinity towards YouTube for whatever
reason if you want to do vlogs or
you want to do longer form content or
like it's just more passionate for you
then then go YouTube but it's gonna be a
little bit harder to stand out and stay
later what do we got more questions
Wilfred
how are you able to adopt the reading
habit uh so first off I would before
picking reading I would adopt the habit
of learning and growing and there's a
number of ways to do that I think I
think reading books was the number one
way to do it I think though I've
switched personally to video I learned a
lot from the videos that I put up like
in the research for the videos I learn a
lot that I then take home and bring into
my business and bring into my life and
so I've substituted a lot of reading
time with video time because being
visual it's the best way for me to learn
podcasts are taking off right you could
learn through podcasts and through
interviews and so it starts with back to
one of the earlier questions just making
a decision that learning is important
that it becomes a priority that now
you're having a hard time fitting into
your schedule in 30 minutes here or an
hour there and it's not consistent it
has to mean something to you it has to
be painful enough like your lack of
growth has to be painful enough you not
learning enough so that you can get to
where you want to go has to be painful
enough so that now you dedicate 30
minutes in a day or however long you
want to spend doing it whether that's
before you go to bed first thing in the
morning you know lunch break whatever
the thing is on your way to work you
just have to make it important and then
whether you want it to be reading or
video or podcast I would I would play up
the one that best suits your learning
style I had to force myself to read a
lot more than I have to listen to or
watch videos watching videos is super
enjoyable for me reading books I would I
would force myself a little bit to do it
I still enjoyed it but but I had to do
the mental game of this is where this is
gonna help me grow and I don't listen to
podcasts at all but I would have to
Podcast was the only way if auditory was
the only way to learn I would really
really have to force myself and sit down
and really get myself set up every
single time I would do it because
learning is really important to me it's
something I really value but if podcast
was the only way to consume content it
would require a lot more dedication
discipline than videos for me so also
finding the path that makes the most
sense for you could really help what do
we got what do we got what do we got
Amanda Mac for editing videos I don't
know Amanda I haven't edit a video in a
long time I started with Windows Movie
Maker since the original videos on my
channel where Windows Movie Maker I
moved to Camtasia to give me more
features and then I hired another and so
but since then I don't know how many
years that's been four or five probably
more years I haven't touched any editing
software so I don't know I don't know
next spec tech at what moment did you
know without a doubt entrepreneurship
was for you and why uh I think when I
when I told my business partner that I
quit on the first company and then I
woke up the next day and I knew that I
couldn't quit not because not because I
didn't want to quit on things I've quit
on lots of stuff I think quitting on
things that don't serve you is fantastic
I think a lot of people stay in
something way too long because they want
to never give up I think you should give
up on lots of things but you don't give
up on the thing that really really means
something to you and so I had
entrepreneurial tendencies growing up
when I was young and selling baseball
cards and all that kind of stuff and I
turned down big paying jobs to be an
entrepreneur but I still had an out when
I turned down those big jobs to make a
hundred K a year and travel around the
world and say I'm gonna go be an
entrepreneur make 300 bucks a month I
wasn't a hundred percent that I wasn't
go back and get a job I gave myself a
year I said I'm gonna try this thing out
for a year and I could always go back
and get another job and if it didn't
work out I'll go get a company I go work
at a company it's fine it would that's
fine
it won't may not be the same
but I can get another job in the
industry and when I started in my
business it wasn't working out and I was
struggling and failing and it was when I
told my business partner that I quit I
woke up the next day I said I can't quit
I have I have to keep going something I
just knew that I had to keep going and
so that was it when I first got into
entrepreneurship with that business it
was really just out of fear of regret I
could deal with the failure but I didn't
want to not know and so that's why I
became an entrepreneur and turned down
the job to go do the company but I
didn't know that it was gonna work out
and I didn't know that I had to be an
entrepreneur and I think you know if
you're thinking about it for all of this
stuff this is this is matters of the
heart you can't think your way through
this you can't sit on the couch and make
a list of pros and cons and say here's
the pros and here's the cons and
whichever one has a greater weight
that's what's gonna win no because the
one bro might outweigh the 102 cons you
have to make the big decisions in life
with your heart and when you find it you
will know and if you haven't found it
yet then keep looking keep searching
keep saying yes keep trying and so I
think that's really important I think
most people don't try entrepreneurship I
think a lot of people just have an idea
and they never take a shot just start
and see do you like it because your
first thing probably won't work out it
doesn't mean that you can't be an
entrepreneur it's more you go and you
try it
did you like it did you
it failed it didn't work but you want to
go back again and do it right just like
your first date is probably not the
person that you married but you tried it
like I like this dating thing I like I
like the idea of being with somebody I'm
gonna do it again just because the first
one didn't work out right that first
date didn't work out I'm gonna get back
on the horse and do it again so I think
it's important that you test it expect
to fail and much more important than the
result this is really important
much more important than the result is
did you enjoy the process did you enjoy
the game you might want to be a singer
and you might create a song and the song
goes nowhere nobody likes it you know
doesn't take off you get only thumbs
downs on that video it doesn't matter
what the results were in the early days
did you enjoy it did you like going and
making a song did you like writing the
lyrics did you like singing it did you
like that entire process because you
liked the process if you keep at it
ultimately you will win if you keep
consistent ultimately you will win but
if you don't like the process you're
never gonna win because the people who
do enjoy it they will crush you and so I
think people look for results too
quickly where the real result is just
you trying something the real result is
just you getting a little bit of
momentum the real result is you just
getting a little bit better each time
and as long as you're still interested
in it then you got to keep going I like
it that's a good answer thank you for
the question
next Saab Lunas what is the best
non-fiction writer you can recommend for
new writers to learn from that's super
subjective honestly my opinion doesn't
even matter on this I would look at who
do you resonate with there's tons of
great authors whether you love Tim
Ferriss whether you love my books
whether you love Seth Godin there's lots
of people to learn from and honestly I
would try to pull different pieces from
everybody I think if you just try to
write like Tim Ferriss you're gonna lose
you have to pull one thing from Tim
Ferriss that you like you know Tim will
put a lot of quotes at the top of a book
like maybe you want to put that for me I
like having books that I can pick up and
put down at any time so every page in
both of these books we're design so that
you can pick it up and put it down you
don't have to read 20 pages to get to
the next chapter and put it down so you
pull different pieces from different
people I think the biggest mistake is
only reading Tim Ferriss or x-y-z author
and that's your only point of reference
I think the more you pick up the more
you learn go to go to your local book
store look through every you know
best-selling author not just in your
niche but outside so nonfiction is a
giant
category right so if you're picking
entrepreneurship or sports writing or
something else you can learn from those
different styles and as long as you take
one little thing that you can apply to
you just like the top ten rules right
top ten rules all ten rules from
everybody may not apply to you but if
you watch a video last night's was on
Jocko will Inc right if if you watch
Jacko's top ten and one or two rules
speak to you that's a win because your
goal is not to be jock a willing your
goal is to be the best you the best
writer right for you and that happens by
pulling one thing from him and two
things from her and four things from
this person and half a thing from over
here and adjusted to make it into the
soup of Awesomeness that is you and so I
think that's how you win so my opinion
doesn't matter there's tons of great
nonfiction books
what matters is what resonates with you
and to get the exposure to as many
nonfiction great writers as possible
next another super chat thank you much
Hugo are another coffee thanks to Hugo
Mel Robbins and her five second rule--
what are your thoughts do you have your
own version of it I'm a planner and I've
always struggled with doing I love Mel I
think she has a lot of great content I'm
a huge fan of her work we've done a
bunch of top ten videos on her another
another piece of content uh I don't use
the five-second rule I just I just don't
find the need for the five-second rule
if I have to force myself to do
something for too long then I didn't I I
stopped doing it I don't know like
waking up in getting out of bed in the
morning is not something I need to psych
myself up to it might be a personality
thing or maybe I need to do harder
things I don't know but I'm not I
haven't applied it in my life for me I
get out of bed I wake up and then I
think much more much more important for
me is the environment and the habits so
what do you do first thing in the
morning is really really really
important so I've developed the identity
for myself that when the alarm rings you
get out of bed when you set a goal you
follow through right no matter what how
big or small the goal is people think
that
an alarm and not getting out of bed it's
okay it's not a big goal that's screwing
you up that's what's really messing you
up all these little goals that you set
for yourself that you don't actually go
out and hit that's messing up your
internal dialogue
it creates an identity for yourself that
says I'm the kind of person who sets a
goal and then does not follow through
and so if you can't do something as
simple as wake up on time and get out of
bed then how are you gonna go off and
accomplish these big ambitions that you
have for yourself you won't you're going
to the gym trying to list that lift a
thousand pounds where you can't even
lift a five-pound dumbbell and so all of
these little micro goals that you set
for yourself like waking up doing it
getting up and doing it then starts the
golden in the reverse order in a
positive way where now I am the person I
am the person who when I say I'm gonna
do something I do it and so you'll be
really careful about the goals that you
set for yourself and then follow through
so set an alarm I set an alarm I'm gonna
get up at seven o'clock I get up and
I've just done that for so long that
it's just part of my identity I don't
need to have a countdown or anything
else to make me do it
from there it's environment habits so
what's the first thing that you do every
morning well for me you know I'll go to
the bathroom and I'll read a page from
my book
the top ten rules it's I wrote the book
for myself because I wanted to be a
daily habit for myself and then I'll
think about one of the points that were
in there and then I'll make a video and
I put it up on my social networks not
YouTube but Twitter Instagram LinkedIn
snapchat a quick like 15-second video a
little mini rant and in reviewing the
message I'm surrounding myself with a
thought leader who's done major things
for the world so already it's tweaking
my mind and then by me then relay my own
version of it me adding my two cents on
I mean giving a message to you guys and
recording it four or five times to get
the feeling and emotion out because in
the morning
I wake up like you guys I'm tired I
maybe you guys wake up fully energized
but I'm tired I got a wipe sleep he's
out of my eyes I got lines on my on my
face from the bed sheets
I would love to sleep
more it doesn't always happen last night
was brutal for me last night I went to
bed around 2:00 and I had too much
coffee I think yes he because my filming
day and so woke up four or five times
and then end up getting up at 7:00 and
Here I am I've got a full day of
interviews full day of podcasts and
Google Hangouts and other interviews
with creators this I already hit my bike
in the morning because I said I was
gonna do it like this is the thing when
you set so important this is so
important for setting your identity when
you set a goal like waking up and going
on the bike that was that was my goal
today I was gonna wake up and I was
gonna go on a bike if I talked to most
people and I said you know I didn't get
to sleep till 2 I wanted to go to sleep
at you know 10:30 11:00 and I didn't get
this legal - and I I woke up four or
five times and I'm just exhausted I have
I have a really big day in front of me
I've got I've got ten interviews in
front of me got to do a live interview
with my YouTube audience I didn't have
my master meeting for Toronto
entrepreneurs tonight that's gonna go to
11 o'clock it's a crazy day it's okay if
I don't to the bike right like everybody
would let you off the hook
everybody would let you off the hook
it's when you start to let yourself off
the hook I had to go and do the bike cuz
I said I was gonna do the bike and so
when you say you're gonna do something I
gave an example with um one of my fans
stopped by the filming yesterday Yuko
and we gave an example of she came and
made me butter tarts right she made me
butter tarts which I'm super excited to
test tomorrow and she told herself I'm
gonna make Kevin butter turds because he
loves butter tarts and I love his
channel and want to go and give him some
support setting that goal as soon as you
said it now it has to get done and
making butter tarts might be easy you
know she likes cooking so it might be
easy but there may be things that get in
the way you know maybe your electricity
goes off maybe your oven blows up you
know maybe a whole bunch of things
happen and you can't do it now what do
you do do you go to your neighbor and
say hey can I borrow your your kitchen I
need to borrow your kitchen eggs and
butter tarts
do you call up a friend and drive over
there to help go make the butter tarts
or do you say I couldn't make it because
the stove didn't work my kitchen is
messed up right now I have no
electricity I can't do it those are the
moments that define you and you may
think it's stupid it's a butter tart it
doesn't matter no it matters is the most
important decision of your life because
when that happens and you say I am going
to make these butter tarts even though I
wouldn't care if she showed up with it
or not and I would let her off the hook
and if she wanted to bring it next time
it's amazing but if she doesn't let
herself off the hook that's the eternal
dialogue that's so important and so when
you find yourself with every single
reason not to do something everything's
stacked against you
everybody else who let you off the hook
you're tired you're burnt out
there's a giant issue in front of you
that's when what I do instead of the
five-second rule I smile when I get
faced with this insane problem I try to
eat it and then I smile it may hit me
immediately like I'm not immune to the
frustration right the frustration the
anger like it'll hit me and then I eat
it and then I smile and the internal
dialogue is happening here is this is my
chance this is my chance to show myself
and this for the world what I'm made of
let's go and I guess that's my version
of the five-second rule it really works
for me
you know I hope it works for you but if
I second well works for you great like
don't do me do you whatever the thing is
and part of what I'm trying to do with
all the videos on my website is share
how different people are doing things
and hopefully some pieces work you might
love Mel for that you might love Mel for
a bunch of other stuff that she talks
about it is amazing and if one thing
from her resonates apply it and win next
help me reach 10k sows with no videos
why question how do you deal with info
overload there like there are so many
great books and videos I want to watch
but enough time so I go through this a
lot I go through this a lot because
there's lots of youtubers that I want to
support I want to help grow I want to I
love their content for me it just
becomes a matter of I want to have a
certain amount of time where I'm
digesting and a certain amount of time
where I'm creating and I know that if
I'm not creating enough I don't I'm not
happy if I'm only consuming and I'm not
making I'm not happy I need to be
creating always why don't you three
videos a day and four posts a day on
Instagram I need to be creating I love
it and so when I find myself as an
example with my youtube I have a watch
later list so I have some channels that
I subscribe to and I have Alex is here
teemo's barking that's really that's
really random it's really random so I
have a youtube channel I have my watch
later list I have YouTube transit I
subscribe to I have a watch later list
and I had my assistant add the videos
from these different channels to my
watch later list and as I saw the watch
later list started to balloon yeah when
I wash later list got to 300 400 videos
I realized I'm never gonna get to this
you know the time I've allocated to this
to to watch these videos and learn
either I need to adjust how much time
I'm spending which then means I'm not
spending time somewhere else which could
be creating and I ultimately often
decide while I'm not willing to do that
I don't want to spend five hours a day
watching YouTube videos because asking
to lead to dissatisfaction somewhere
else so then I have to make a decision
I've subscribed to 40 channels which
three am I gonna have to drop to be able
to make that watch list later go down
and so I think that I think that's super
important I think you have to recognize
you have a certain amount of time to
learn and invest in yourself and it's
great and that helps you grow but if
you're not taking action on it you're
not creating you're not making something
new then ultimate
you gonna fail and so how much time do
you want to apply to it it's not just
information overload it's also
opportunity overload my biggest
challenge right now is drowning
opportunities there's so many people who
want to do different creative projects
and I'm sure I'm saying no to a whole
bunch of things that could really really
help me but to take on one project it
means I'm saying no to a bunch of other
things and anytime I feel myself wanting
to go off and do something if it's a
one-off thing you can you can stretch
yourself a little bit you can stay up a
little bit later you can wake up a
little bit earlier if it's a one-off
thing you can do that but if it's a
consistent thing eventually you're gonna
burn out eventually you won't be able to
handle it and so anytime I feel myself
consistently being pulled and stretched
in too many directions I know I have to
edit and adjust my schedule when I went
from just being an investor in TDs to
owning it I had to dedicate a huge chunk
of my time a good chunk of Mondays and
parts of my evenings to run TDs to help
with the operations to help train Alex
and that meant I could do other things
on Monday right
same thing when when I brought on Lily
my plan before going to work with Lily
was I wanted to create an entrepreneur
cafe that was what was on my mind I
talked about on this channel you guys
probably heard it the hardcore fans I
wanted to create a place for
entrepreneurs to come to and work and be
inspired and have it have a cafe the
place for entrepreneurs to go to and as
soon as I started working with Lily like
alright I can't do that I know losing
the chat don't feel guilty Lily that's
my decision
right I can't do that I can't do both so
I had to pick so before going with Lily
I had to recognize internally I am NOT
going to launch my entrepreneur cafe at
least any time soon and so I'm okay and
I live with that and when you get these
opportunities or information for me the
default is always going back to my
calendar because you can be super human
for a short amount of time but it's not
going to be sustainable and so as soon
as you feel yourself being stretched for
me I think I think the way
way to do it is as soon as you feel
micro stretching you go back to
adjusting your schedule in your calendar
even even business versus family time
how much time you want to spend with
your significant other if you feel
stretching if you feel like you're doing
too much work and you need to spend more
personal time then before what most
people do is they don't make the
adjustment in the calendar immediately
they wait six months a year two years
too late and then they have a crisis
that forces them to change it's like
you're going to the doctor and you're
getting these reports saying hey your
your cholesterol is high your
cholesterol is high there's all these
issues that are coming up but you don't
do anything till you get a heart attack
adjust like don't wait for this insane
crisis to come Lilly calls it the bus of
change don't worry don't wait for the
bus to hit you and you almost die
adjust sooner adjust in the micro
constantly next Michael how do you find
new books to help you grow kind of
talked about that gogo earlier on in the
chat in the video you can watch it
Pranav I'm a teenager and I have great
plans but no resources what do i do
first off eliminate the mindset of lack
of resources you are you are walking
around in in a wasteland your mindset is
a waistline right now if you are walking
around with that attitude that I don't
have resources you have lost you have
already lost the people who have won
your idols your heroes where where does
it you look up to started with less than
what you already have right now and if
you're walking around saying I don't
have any resources and I'm too young to
start anything
then guess what you do you're right you
don't have resources and you're too
young and you're gonna lose because of
it but ultimately you've lost because of
your mindset the ultimate resource is
your resourcefulness look at the people
who are the kids of rich people they
have all the resources in the world they
have all the money in the world if the
best education the connections to
everywhere it's very rare that the kids
of rich people go off to create amazing
businesses it's not about having
resources
it's about being resourceful so as soon
as you there's a
quote from Steve Wozniak they said stop
focusing on what you don't have and
instead start thinking about what you
can do with what you do have stop
focusing on what you don't have and
instead focus on what you can do with
what you do have if you can get that
especially at 17 if you can get that you
are set up to win for life never ever
ever ever ever ever complain come to
another chat talk to your friends or
your family or anybody else ever
including yourself never say I don't
have resources never you say that you
lose you got angry but but it's true
and I want you to win next
christ-centered
ironworks $5 super chat what's up
another coffee Thank You christ-centered
ironworks Haven just stopped forging for
a moment to say thank you for all the
encouragement every day god bless hey I
appreciate that man means a lot good
luck with your chain I'll good luck with
everything you're doing get back to four
Jean I love it doing the work doing the
work don't just consume create I love it
next row enact classes things to keep in
mind while starting while going live on
YouTube things to keep in mind while
starting while going live YouTube so one
I would say if you haven't already
started then you need to start before
you even start asking questions just
start just start just start get make it
test it taste it see it a new feature
comes out I just got an alert about
Instagram and their new focus feature so
you can you can take a picture or make a
video focus and it'll blur out the
background and put you in focus like
great a new thing comes out I want to
try it I want to taste it I want to see
it so many people are worried about
having the best and doing it perfectly
and then they never start it will never
be perfect just go just start this
magical day is never gonna come do it
right now today is your magical day
today is our magical day everybody say
that out loud
today is my magical day right Alex today
is your magic do it you have one idea do
it do it stop waiting
stop asking you don't need anybody's
permission just do it it's gonna suck
that's awesome
do it taste it oh my mom taste it that's
what you need to do very excited today
on the Thursday Thursday morning to give
you some tips to you have to figure out
what your style is gonna be you have to
figure if you're gonna be doing
something with your audience or not if
it's gonna be you documenting your day
you doing a Q&A like this you can look
at other live videos and get ideas
inspiration people look up to but at the
end of the day just do just do just do
just do just do like those little micro
things don't matter you'll figure it out
they matter because they matter you'll
figure it out though more important than
figuring out those little tiny details
is just doing it get your live stream
going today like right after this you
should go live right after this go live
and just start and say I don't know what
I'm doing hey guys I'm testing this out
this is probably gonna suck I'm thinking
about going live on YouTube here we go
and say whatever comes to your mind and
then get off and realize wow that really
sucked okay I get I get how this thing
works and then tomorrow you make it
better when I first started doing
Instagram live it was it was a disaster
it was a disaster people's internet
connections were terrible I didn't know
how to add people to the chat it's a
bunch of me like super close up like
this sorry guy I don't know what's
happening I don't know nobody remembers
that one and instead of spending six
months trying to figure out how to get
an Instagram live to work do right now
there's planning and doing and if you
plan if you're the planner you need to
do more and if you're the doer you need
to plan more if you're the doer and
you're all you do is doo doo doo doo doo
and there's no direction no planning no
strategy
you're gonna lose - you have to plan a
little bit more but most people just are
stuck in planning mode plan plan plan
plan plan plan plan do you have to do
more you have to force yourself to do
because otherwise you're gonna lose good
luck after this go live any of you guys
who are
thinking about going live on your
YouTube channel or on Instagram after
this thing go live that's it period go
live right now stop waiting this is it
this is what I was talking about with
the decisions the goal-setting with
yourself the identity right here's a
chance here's a chance for all of you
who are scared to go live this is it I
want to go live I'm scared everything
just lay down a challenge I should go
live I really want to go live but I'm
but maybe I'll go live but you know what
I'm not gonna do it you get off this
call the energy goes away Emmons not
here anymore
your energy drops you don't go do it you
have just told yourself that when I get
faced with the challenge my default is
to shrink right here's something I want
to do but I'm scared to do it and so I'm
gonna shrink I'm not gonna do it who
cares what you do on on YouTube live
what are you so concerned about nobody's
paying attention anyway but then the
next time that you're faced with a
challenge or out between in front of you
guess what you're gonna do again shrink
and the next time shrink and the next
time shrink you've built this identity
of plain small and it's gonna happen
your entire life
this is how you start to change it here
right now you have something you want to
forget YouTube live everything else you
guys have something that you want to do
that you're scared of doing just do it
find some small way expect it fail
expect to suck and do it do it do it do
it do it do it do it because now what
you did you went to the gym and you
lifted that five-pound dumbbell and
instead of saying I'm never gonna hit
the gym and you want to be a body build
that you want it you want to look good
you want to be strong but you never hit
in the gym now you've done it
and the biggest win is not that the
thing you make is gonna be great because
it won't it's gonna suck it's gonna be
the worst thing ever
you'll look at and be totally
embarrassed and it was anything better
than that you won but the victory is in
the momentum the victory is in that
subtle mindset shift at huh I did
something this time I was scared to do
it and then I actually did it
that's how you win so anybody who's
scared of doing something right now I
hope you use this energy and just go off
and do it expect the suck and do it next
[ __ ] I will go live after this in all
caps
yes real knack classes listen I'm gonna
do I'm gonna join you live I'm gonna
bookmark your I'm gonna bookmark your
chain on bookmarking you Channel right
now go to channel row knack ruin our
classes I have to get another call so I
can join in super quick investing and
self-help tutorials row knack classes
I'm gonna join on your livestream and
give you some love in the chat as soon
as we finish here
good go yes I love it other people
Lilly's gonna be watching too
yes and then go live again tomorrow and
the next day and the next day and get
better and today guess what you're gonna
suck and it's gonna be amazing and we're
all gonna cheer and how bad it is and
tomorrow it's gonna be even better I
love it I love it I love it I love it
good ok next what do we got how much
time we have we're running tight uh what
else what else what else we got people
tagging me Zach what are the best ways
to stand out from other people
professionally the best way to stand out
is to figure out what is so different
and amazing about you that sounds very
fluffy but it's so true you know I I
think you need to figure out so I mean
the secret to getting the head is is
doing your job well the secret to to
getting ahead in entrepreneurship in a
career path is just really doing your
job well and it's actually not that hard
because most people are doing just
enough work not to get fired most people
don't have great ambitions most people
don't love the work that they're doing
and so you stand out by just showing up
that's how low the bar is just showing
up just having done a little bit extra
work and research just by thinking a
little bit beyond what they were asking
to do right whatever they ask you to do
first of all do it and be there early
that already puts you ahead of 75% of
the people and then always think about
what's next like what's the extension of
this thing how can I add more value
there asked me to do this I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna get it done it's gonna be
early it's gonna be on time it's gonna
be on budget and I'm gonna add this
little extra piece that I think might
help whether it does or not just that
extra initiative already is is win but
that's something everybody can do that's
not even speaking to what you're great
at
alone though puts you ahead of 90% of
the people that's how sad that's how sad
it is
it's how little people are committed to
the thing that they are doing but if you
really want to win hard you really want
to win hard you got to figure out what
makes you tick for me
it's belief right I believe in people I
care more about people than I should
given our relationship I care about you
winning I don't even know you and I want
you to win I want you to win so hard
it's it's I'm gonna think about it it's
it's why I'm doing this workshop in
Toronto because I want people for three
days right I want people want to be
thought leaders in three days and I want
them so badly to win I want my hooks to
get in and I want this energy to not
just last for an hour like we're doing
here but I want you to be moved because
I care some I care more about you than I
should for a three-day event or for a
one-hour session like this it just means
so much to me and so I lean in on that
and so you need to figure out what the
thing is that makes you tick and how you
can bring that if you love the Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers and you love that
show and you have all the collectibles
and all the dolls and and you go to
every trade show and you dress up like a
Mighty Morphin Power Ranger for every
Halloween and you dress up even on on
Halloween days it's your thing great
right what can you take from the Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers and apply to your
professional career and at first it's
not gonna seem obvious but there's a lot
of things there's a lot a lot a lot of
things there's a lot of lessons that can
be learned that you can apply to your
job and so take that equivalent whatever
the thing is that you love doing
whatever you obsess about how can you
bring it into your career that's gonna
help you get beyond the 90% but honestly
the 90 for just getting just showing up
on time and just doing the work that
people ask you to do on-time on-budget
your head a seventy five percent of the
world thinking that extra step to say
hey how can I bring a little bit more
value they want me to do this but how
can I add this here's what I think could
also help whether it actually does or
not put your head at ninety percent of
the world you want to be in the top 1%
and you got to figure out what makes you
tick and bring that to everything you do
to
guys gonna end a little bit early
because I want to hop on row knock
classes livestream right now and I have
to do interviews after this so I'm
giving it five minutes we're cutting
this out five minutes early so we can
hop on to row nack classes I'm gonna
actually for those in the live chat I'm
gonna link it up here in the chat below
if anybody wants to join in thank you
guys so much for watching listen guys
it's it's almost noon here Eastern for
me there's a lot of time left and today
we got a lot of time to make something
happen whether whether you're about to
go to bed in 20 minutes you could still
make something happen you can take a
little bit of momentum you could still
go live on YouTube with 20 minutes left
in the day do the thing do something
that you will be proud of to say this
day matters it's just not another it's
not just another Thursday this day
matters this is your magical day right
we all said it
it's your magical day let's see it
happen thank you guys so much for the
love I believe in you I hope we continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love see you soon